LSD, Psilocybin, Meskalin und Ayahuasca.
Alles gefährliche Drogen, oder?! Das ist
zumindest die Idee, die man bekommt, weil
die Stoffe international verboten sind. Aber:
Das Verbot schränkte nicht nur den
Missbrauch dieser Substanzen ein,
sondern auch ihre Erforschung
als medizinische Wirkstoffe.
Und hier gibt es richtig viele unglaubliche
Erfolgsstories: Psychedelika sollen gegen
Depressionen helfen, Angststörungen
heilen und auch bei Cluster-Kopfschmerzen,
posttraumatischen Belastungsstörungen und
Substanzmissbrauch helfen. Könnten diese
Drogen also am Ende sogar Leben retten,
wenn sie richtig eingesetzt werden?
Seit einiger Zeit wird wieder richtig viel an
klassischen Psychedelika geforscht. Es gibt
einen regelrechten Boom an spannenden,
neuen Studien. Wir haben sie gelesen,
haben mit Expertinnen aus dem Gebiet gesprochen
und beantworten euch heute alle Fragen zum Thema.
Fast jeder Mensch erlebt irgendwann eine
depressive Phase. Man ist demotiviert und
traurig, müde, unkonzentriert und lustlos.
Das Robert-Koch-Institut hat ermittelt,
dass in den Jahren 2019 und 2020 rund 7 bis
10 Prozent der zufällig am Telefon befragten
Erwachsenen in den zwei Wochen vor der
Befragung depressive Symptome hatten.
Je nach schwere der Erkrankung fällt
die Behandlung unterschiedlich aus.
Viele Menschen empfinden Depressionen
als Stigma, da kann eine professionelle
Aufklärung helfen. Man animiert sie auch, sich
in der Natur zu bewegen und unter Menschen zu
gehen. Wenn das nicht genügt, wird zusätzlich
oft eine Psychotherapie verschrieben. Und bei
schweren Fällen kann diese Therapie dann
noch mit Medikamenten unterstützt werden,
nämlich Antidepressiva. Antidepressiva
helfen vielen, aber leider nicht allen. Bei
bis zu 30% der Menschen mit Depressionen
schlagen all diese Therapien nicht an.
Wir brauchen also bessere Medikamente. Und
da hoffen einige Forscherinnen und Forscher
auf Stoffe mit einem vielleicht etwas
fragwürdigen Ruf: klassische Psychedelika.
Die klassischen Psychedelika sind LSD, Psilocybin,
Meskalin und DMT. Sie werden aus Pflanzen und
Pilzen hergestellt oder extrahiert. LSD ist die
Abwandlung eines Stoffes aus dem Purpurbraunen
Mutterkornpilz. Der wächst auf Weizen und
ist super giftig. Die anderen klassischen
Psychedelika stammen aus Pilzen und Pflanzen, die
seit Jahrtausenden in schamanistischen Ritualen
Verwendung finden. DMT ist der Wirkstoff
in Ayahuasca, einem Tee aus verschiedenen
Pflanzen und was passiert, wenn man den trinkt,
das könnt ihr euch bei Tomatolix ansehen.
Aber wie genau wirken diese Substanzen? [korrigierter Text:]
Dieklassischen Psychedelika sind Agonisten – also Aktivierer – eines bestimmtenSerotonin-Rezeptors.
Diese Wirkung führt – vermutlich – dazu, dass die Hirnrinde
weniger Feedback an die Regionen zurückgeben kann,
die zum Beispiel Sinneseindrücke verarbeiten.
Was dann passiert, wird oft als
eine äußerst intensive Erfahrung
beschrieben – ein Trip. Man verspürt
in der Regel einen leichten Schwindel,
Rastlosigkeit und Halluzinationen. Zum Beispiel
sieht man kaleidoskopische Farben und Formen.
Ob ein Trip als Traum oder Alptraum erlebt wird,
hängt von den inneren und äußeren Umständen ab.
Forscher sprechen hier von “Set und Setting”.
“Set” steht für Mindset; es geht also um die
Absichten und Erwartungen, mit denen zum
Beispiel eine Probandin Psilocybin nimmt,
aber auch um das seelische Befinden
in dem Moment. Das “Setting” sind die
äußeren Bedingungen. Also die anwesenden Menschen
und zum Beispiel die Gestaltung des Raums.
Für die evidenzbasierte Medizin
wurden Psychedelika interessant,
nachdem Albert Hofmann in den 40er
und 50er Jahren LSD und Psilocybin
aus Pilzen hergestellt beziehungsweise
extrahiert und an sich selbst getestet hat.
Wegen ihrer aufheiternden Wirkung
wurden Psychedelika daraufhin als
Mittel gegen Depressionen vorgeschlagen
und entsprechende Forschung betrieben.
Aber nach dem internationalen Verbot der
Psychedelika Anfang der 70er, wurde das
extrem schwierig. Nur wenige Projekte wurden
bewilligt, teilweise wurde sogar im Untergrund
geforscht. Erst seit den frühen 2000ern
ist die offizielle Forschung wiederbelebt
und zurzeit boomt das Interesse geradezu
– vor allem in den USA, aber auch in Europa.
Dabei müssen die alten Erkenntnisse erst noch
einmal überprüft werden. Denn die Methoden
aus den frühen Jahren der Psychedelika-Forschung
sind inzwischen überholt. Es werden deshalb viele
klinische Studien durchgeführt, um die Anwendung
der unterschiedlichen Psychedelika zu testen.
Bei der Behandlung von Depressionen mit
Psychedelika wird natürlich darauf geachtet,
dass “Set und Setting” stimmen. Das bedeutet,
die Probandinnen und Probanden werden erst
einmal über den Versuch und das jeweils
verwendete Psychedelikum informiert und
so auf die Behandlung vorbereitet. Am
Tag der Behandlung wird darauf geachtet,
dass die Versuchsperson in einem seelisch
guten Zustand ist, also zum Beispiel keine
akuten Angstzustände hat. Der Proband
oder die Probandin wird während des
Trips von medizinischem Personal begleitet,
das natürlich auch die Dosis vorbereitet hat.
Meistens wird das Licht gedimmt, manchmal
auch leise Musik gespielt. Je nach Studie
wurden ein oder zwei solcher Sessions gemacht.
Nach der Behandlung werden die Probandinnen und
Probanden dann je nach Studie unterschiedlich lang
weiter betreut und ihr Wohlbefinden abgefragt.
Wir haben uns vor allem *diese* Meta-Analyse
hier im Detail angeschaut und einige weitere
Meta-Analysen gesichtet . Sie fassen die
Ergebnisse von Einzelstudien zusammen,
um ein Gesamtbild der Forschung wiederzugeben.
Die Frage war: Helfen Psychedelika
gegen Depressionen und wenn ja, wie gut?
Insgesamt erscheint uns die Datenbasis
da tatsächlich noch nicht sehr gut. Zum
Beispiel wurden hier aus über 100 Studien zum
Thema nur neun in die Analyse aufgenommen,
davon wurde 6 mal Psilocybin getestet, zweimal
Ayahuasca und einmal LSD. Das heißt, die
Ergebnisse für Psilocybin dominieren die Datenlage
in dieser Analyse. Auch die anderen Meta-Analysen
haben am Ende nur wenige Studien betrachtet, aber
nicht immer dieselben. Und auch die jeweiligen
Autorinnen und Autoren finden, dass man einfach
noch mehr wissenschaftliche Forschung braucht.
Ein Problem für klinische Studien
an Psychedelika ist vor allem die
sogenannte “Verblindung”. Der Goldstandard in der
medizinischen Forschung sind ja randomisierte,
doppelt-verblindete Kontrollstudien. Also: wir
haben zwei repräsentative Gruppen. Eine erhält
das Medikament, die andere ein Placebo. Weder die
Probandinnen und Probanden, noch die Forschenden,
sollen wissen, wer in welcher Gruppe ist, bis die
Daten erhoben und ausgewertet sind. Das ist die
besagte Verblindung. Aber – Überraschung – jeder
merkt halt sofort, ob er auf einem psychedelischen
Trip ist. Ein zweites Problem ist der sogenannte
Publikations-Bias. Es werden eher klar positive
Ergebnisse veröffentlicht, als negative oder
unklare Ergebnisse. Aber diese Probleme mit
der Forschung haben die Autorinnen und Autoren der
Meta-Analysen so gut wie möglich berücksichtigt.
Insgesamt kommen sie und
andere Forschende zum Schluss,
dass – Trommelwirbel bitte – Therapien mit
klassischen Psychedelika sicher und wirksam sind.
Besonders fällt auf, wie schnell sie
wirken. Antidepressiva wirken meist
erst nach einigen Wochen der Einnahme. Aber
eine Psychedelika-Behandlung beendet eine
depressive Phase sofort. Das ist übrigens
auch bei Ketamin der Fall. Ketamin gehört
nicht zu den klassischen Psychedelika,
weil es eine andere Wirkung hat. Aber es
wird seit kurzem auf ganz ähnliche Weise für die
Behandlung schwerster Depressionen eingesetzt.
Nach einer Behandlung wirkt Ketamin bis zu drei
Wochen nach. Aber die Therapien mit klassischen
Psychedelika vermindern die Schwere der
Symptome teilweise mehrere Monate lang.
Bevor wir zu den Nebenwirkungen kommen - und
glaubt mir, ihr werdet positiv überrascht
sein - möchte ich euch über ein anderes
Thema mit massiven Nebenwirkungen aufklären.
Der durchschnittliche Doktor-Whatson-Zuschauer
ist gleichzeitig auch ein Heavy-Internet-User.
Und mit jeder Online-Anmeldung, jeder
Registrierung und jedem Einkauf gebt
ihr großzügig eure Daten weiter. Leider geht
nicht jede Plattform sinnvoll mit euren Daten
um. Das betrifft im besten Fall nur euren
Namen, häufig auch eure E-Mail-Adresse,
aber in ganz extremen Fällen
sogar eure Fotos oder Bankdaten.
Deshalb will ich euch auf Incogni aufmerksam
machen. Das ist ein unscheinbares Tool,
das ich persönlich empfehlen
kann, weil es genau das tut,
was eigentlich jeder machen sollte: Es löscht
eure privaten Daten, wo sie nicht hingehören!
Dafür müsst ihr nur eure betroffenen
E-Mail-Adressen angeben und schon
legt Incogni los. Das Tool fängt an, nach
euren Daten Im Netz zu suchen und schaut
in erster Linie auf Plattformen nach, die
Datensätze zum Verkauf anbieten. In einem
zweiten Schritt kann Incogni dann
Datenlöschanträge für euch stellen.
Bei mir wurden beim ersten Mal direkt
60 Löschanträge gestellt. Aus eigener
Erfahrung lege ich euch daher ans Herz,
euren Datenschutz ernst zu nehmen.
Schaut unbedingt mal bei Incogni vorbei [On
Screen: Link in der Videobeschreibung] und
wenn ihr es selbst mal ausprobieren wollt, dann
lasst euch nicht unseren Rabatt entgehen. Mit
unserem Code “DOKTORWHATSON” bekommt ihr
nämlich 60%-Rabatt auf ein Jahresabo. Und
falls ihr doch nicht zufrieden seid, habt
ihr natürlich 30 Tage Geld-zurück-Garantie.
Okay, wow! Klassische Psychedelika
wirken also anscheinend schneller
als Antidepressiva und sogar länger als Ketamin!
Aber was ist mit Nebenwirkungen? Sind
Psychedelika nicht gefährliche Drogen?
Zunächst einmal sind klassische Psychedelika viel
sicherer als Ketamin und andere Substanzen. Man
kennt zum Beispiel keine tödliche Dosis
für LSD oder Psilocybin. Man weiß nur,
dass sie 1.000 Mal höher sein muss, als
die Dosis, die einen Trip auslöst. Auch
die Gefahr, abhängig zu werden, ist bei
den klassischen Psychedelika sehr gering,
weil man bei wiederholtem Gebrauch gegen
die euphorisierenden und psychedelischen
Wirkungen resistent wird. Und das kann man
mit höheren Dosen auch nicht ausgleichen.
LSD und Psilocybin sind in der Hinsicht
deshalb sogar ungefährlicher als Koffein!
Kurzzeitige negative Effekte – also
umgangssprachlich, ein “schlechter
Trip” – kommen im klinischen Setting selten
vor. Lang anhaltende negative Nachwirkungen,
wie das Triggern von Psychosen, überhaupt
nicht. Das wird vor allem auf die
optimalen Bedingungen bei der Behandlung
zurückgeführt. Außerdem wurden Menschen,
die schon einmal psychotische Episoden
erlebt haben, von den klinischen Studien
ausgeschlossen. Aber auch in den Studien, die
nicht in diese Meta-Analysen eingegangen sind,
sind Berichte von Psychosen wenig mehr als
anekdotisch. Was tatsächlich bei relativ vielen
Menschen zu passieren scheint, sind Flashbacks.
Das ist das gelegentliche Wiederauftreten
von leichten Halluzinationen für ein paar
Sekunden bis Minuten. Aber das vergeht wieder,
wurde eher als angenehm empfunden und hatte auch
keine negativen Auswirkungen auf den Alltag.
Als Partydrogen sind klassische Psychedelika aber
immer noch riskant. Denn im privaten Rahmen sind
Set und Setting unkontrolliert und im Rausch kann
man sich und andere gefährden. Und schließlich
weiß man bei Pillen, die man sich illegal
besorgt, nie, was da alles wirklich drin ist.
Aber als Medikament im klinischen Kontext
scheinen klassische Psychedelika extrem sicher
zu sein und gegen hartnäckige Depressionen gut
zu wirken. Krass. Aber wie machen sie das genau?
Die aktuelle Hypothese ist, dass die klassischen
Psychedelika – und auch Ketamin – das Gehirn für
ein paar Tage bis Wochen in einen Zustand höherer
Neuroplastizität versetzen. Neuroplastizität
ist die Fähigkeit von Neuronen zu wachsen
und Verbindungen miteinander zu knüpfen,
zu kappen, zu verstärken oder zu schwächen. Das
Gehirn ist dadurch lern- und anpassungsfähiger,
und damit auch empfänglicher für
zum Beispiel eine Psychotherapie.
Diese Hypothese wird dadurch gestützt,
dass Psychedelika im Tierversuch einige
Marker von Neuroplastizität verstärken.
Solche Versuche kann man bei Menschen
aber nicht so einfach machen. Deshalb ist
die Evidenz da auch noch nicht so klar.
Die Forschung soll übrigens auch klären,
ob die psychedelische Erfahrung wirklich
notwendig für den Effekt ist. Es ist ja denkbar,
dass man die Neuroplastizität auch ohne
die psychedelische Erfahrung erhöhen kann.
Dann könnte man vielleicht wirksame Medikamente
entwickeln, die die Psychotherapie unterstützen,
ohne gleichzeitig als Partydroge zu fungieren.
Auch für Menschen mit Angststörungen und
Post-Traumatischer-Belastungsstörung wäre das
von Vorteil, weil sie ein höheres Risiko haben,
bei einem psychedelischen Trip
negative Erfahrungen zu machen.
Ich würde davon ausgehen, dass klassische
Psychedelika in Zukunft die Therapien für
Depression ergänzen werden. Es gibt inzwischen
einzelne Forschungsgruppen und auch erste Praxen,
die Sondergenehmigungen bekommen haben, um mit
klassischen Psychedelika arbeiten zu dürfen.
Ansonsten bleiben diese Substanzen
in Deutschland erstmal verboten.
Im klinischen Zusammenhang haben sich
vor allem LSD und Psilocybin als sehr
sicher bewiesen. Außerdem scheinen sie eine
erstaunliche Wirksamkeit bei der Behandlung
von Depressionen und Angststörungen zu
haben. Auch bei Cluster-Kopfschmerzen,
Post-Traumatischer-Belastungsstörung
und Substanzmissbrauch gibt es wohl
vielversprechende Ergebnisse. Dass alle Substanzen
dieser Gruppe gleich für so viele Einsatzgebiete
die perfekte Lösung sein sollen, klingt aber doch
zu gut, um wahr zu sein. Das finden auch viele der
Forscherinnen und Forscher. Und genau deshalb
braucht es eben mehr gute klinische Studien.
Und auch die Grundlagenforschung zur
Neuroplastizitäts-Hypothese dürfte
sich lohnen. Denn sie könnte zur Entwicklung
ganz neuer, effektiver Medikamente führen,
die vielleicht nicht die
Erkrankungen direkt heilen,
aber zumindest die Psychotherapie
effektiver machen können.
Alles megaspannend! Wir halten Euch
natürlich auf dem Laufenden.
Abonniert gerne den Kanal, um das nicht zu verpassen.
Bis dahin, bleibt neugierig, Euer Cedric